thank you don't we this is yet another
example of Microsoft researchers
commitment to work very closely with
para groups to improve our products next
I'm going to invite a lead researcher
Quintin to come to tell us about Sora
the cutting edge next generation a
software-defined radio platform right
Thank You phone call instruction and
welcome everyone on so today the one is
complication is can very prevalent so
actually became the essential part of a
daily life so look at your phone
actually they're already lumber our
radios technology have been buried there
for example we have Bluetooth Wi-Fi jsm
for voice voice call and the 3g for the
data service and there are also many
other water technology that they
designed to integrate to help you be
created connectivity and better
experience however traditionally age
different radio technology is
implemented with the specialized hug so
integrated old this kind of heated units
were a hardware into a single platform
it's very difficult and caustic so then
comes an idea of software radio the idea
is to replace all this specialized
hardware with a common a general-purpose
computing platform then you can
implement all this video functionality
with software so the software video
actually translate the communication
problem from a hardware problem to a
software problem so the obvious is the
benefit is obvious because the software
brings you the greater flexibility and
the programmability so you can write a
bad wireless protocols that understand
and adapt to the environment and deliver
better performance
further the cause also can be saved
because all this video functionality I
rely on the same common on computing
platform it's also a great research
platform that you can quickly do the
prototyping and get a result also easier
to develop and the reducer cycle from
research to the market but the real
challenge here is that if the software
can present this high-speed introducing
blow at a certain speed as a special
highway so let's motivate the project
sora let's carry the in Microsoft
Research Asia so the goal of this solar
project is to build a powerful subtree
do based on existing community PC
platform actually we developed two key
technology to enable this one thing is
that we take advantage of the country pc
pc bus that we use natives the
pcie-based pcie interface to build the
interface that can transfer the
Dementors wireless signals from the
video from an a to the pc memory as a
multi gigabit per second circle the
second is a bunch of software
innovations that make full use of the
modern multi-core CPUs that's using the
parallel computing to speed up your
digital signal processing also to
support real hard process the real hard
programming so with all this technology
actually we can implement the arc on the
latest while is like a 0 2 G level but
also can supposed the future while
standard not ltd after this result the
Soraa had been well recognized our world
wallet we were popular paper the guys
the best paper world and women number of
the better demo word in this top
conference
and in this January the communication of
ACN has highlighted the result of Sarah
and the such that it is one of the most
significant the wise paper is recently
so we have make this aura technology are
open for the academic research MSR has
sponsored the academic program that we
collaborate with 18 universities
worldwide to do the widest research base
of a solar technology we also shape this
the strip that as an immense honest of
the reader extender kit that you can you
can get it from a downloaded from our
website and now he's already have 170
users and actively use the auto
technology do the research so with all
these efforts are just emphasize that we
are trying to want to closely
collaborative org academic partners to
empower the academic wise research with
this cutting-edge technology so let's
conclude my part and send you for your
attention